bonjour à tous
elle la france compte plus de 2 millions
de personnes handicapées elles cinq ans
après l'entrée en vigueur de la loi du
11 février 2005 sur l'égalité des droits
des personnes handicapées
le bilan est positif elle met le sénat
se penche sur les difficultés qui
perdure c'est l'objet de la proposition
de loi ump examinée hier
elles concernent notamment le
fonctionnement des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées
ces maisons mises en place en 2006 sont
le lieu unique d'accueil des handicapés
elles ont pour but de centraliser les
informations afin de leur faciliter les
démarches mais leur fonctionnement est
entravé par de nombreuses difficultés
le personnel y est instable et précaires
et les garanties de financement
insuffisante la proposition de loi ump
vise donc à résoudre ces
dysfonctionnements est tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle est très bonne
séance pour madame le ministre mes chers
collègues il s'agit donc de la
discussion de proposition de loi tendant
à améliorer le fonctionnement des
maisons départementales des personnes
handicapées et portant diverses
dispositions relatives à la politique du
handicap dans la discussion générale est
la parole est à monsieur paul blanc qui
est auteur de la proposition doit et
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la présidente madame le
ministre mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs
cette proposition de loi est
l'aboutissement d'une réflexion engagée
voilà plus d'un an avec notre collègue
annie jarraud vergnolle sur les
dysfonctionnements des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées et plus largement sur les
améliorations à apporter à la loi
handicap du 11 février 2005 elle
retranscrit les propositions adoptées
alors dans notre commission
ce qui a conduit plusieurs de nos
collègues elle a cosigné et je tenais à
les en remercier chaleureusement le
texte comporte deux parties la première
est consacrée au fonctionnement et au
financement des mdph la seconde traite
plus généralement de la politique du
handicap notamment de la prise en charge
des frais de compensation de l'emploi
des personnes handicapées et de
l'accessibilité fonctionnement des
financements des mdph
vous le savez des mdph sont confrontées
à trois types de difficultés
l'instabilité de leur personnel
diversité de leur statut
l'insuffisance de garanties à court
terme de leurs ressources certaines
lourdeurs administratives qui subsistent
dans l'intrus dans l'instruction des
demandes en ce qui concerne le
traitement des demandes le texte prévoit
plusieurs dispositions
la première fixée à 35 heures
hebdomadaires la durée minimale
d'ouverture des mdph et leurs
permanences téléphoniques afin d'assurer
une qualité l'accueil équivalente sur
l'ensemble du territoire
la deuxième carif île et compétence
territoriale des mdph en retenant la
notion de domicile de secours de
continuité des droits ouverts même en
cas de déménagement la troisième
autorise la md les commissions
départementales d'autonomie pour les
personnes handicapées à statuer
lorsqu'elles sont en réunit en section
locale ou spécialisés enfin le texte
tend à favoriser une meilleure prise en
compte du caractère pluridisciplinaire
des décisions prises par le tribunal du
contentieux de l'incapacité et de
l'accord national de l'incapacité et de
la tarification de l'assurance accidents
du travail
j'en viens à la question sensible des
financements chacun le sait les mdph
rencontrent des problèmes financiers
importants du fait de la compensation
partielle des postes mis à disposition
par l'état lorsqu'il ne sont pas pourvus
mais aussi faute de trésorerie et de
plans pluriannuels de financement
plusieurs dispositions du texte
permettent d'y remédier et d'offrir aux
mdph une meilleure visibilité financière
d'abord la stabilisation du statut des
mdph
le choix du gip ayant finalement été
actée par les conseils généraux
o qui voilent avantages d'une certaine
souplesse de fonctionnement est un
signal positif quant au maintien de la
participation financière de l'état
en outre cette solution permet de
préserver la participation des
associations qui contribuent
bénévolement au fonctionnement des mdph
ensuite l'exonération des mains dps du
paiement de la taxe sur les salaires
environ 1,2 million d'euros d'économies
permettra au gip qu'ils acquittent de
dégager les moyens supplémentaires pour
employer de nouveaux personnels enfin la
mise en place une convention triennale
d'objectifs de moyens entre chaque mdph
l'état et le conseil général permettra
de préciser les modalités de
compensation des postes que l'état s'est
engagé à transférer au gip ainsi que les
moyens supplémentaires qu'il apporte en
cas d'augmentation des missions
assignées aux maisons la signature de
cette convention
dans chaque département contribuera
ainsi à clarifier les engagements de
l'état et a donné aux maisons
départementales de meilleures garanties
financières
s'agissant des personnels le texte issu
de la commission comporte trois mesures
visant à déstabiliser à mieux les former
et enrichir leurs textes leurs
perspectives de carrière
la première autorisée le gip a recruté
les agents en contrat de droit public à
durée déterminée afin d'offrir à ses
personnages de meilleures perspectives
de carrière au sein des mdph la deuxième
permet au centre national de la fonction
publique territoriale d'ouvrir les
formations qu'il dispense généralement
aux seuls fonctionnaires territoriaux à
tous les personnels quel que soit leur
statut et de prélever les cotisations
correspondantes
la troisième mesure adoptée pendant
commission prévoit d'aménager le régime
de la mise à disposition des personnels
de l'état en portant la durée de trois à
cinq ans avec un vérin un préavis plus
longue de six mois et en instaurant un
système de mise à disposition contre
remboursement
dans ce schéma l'état demeure employeurs
et la mdph lui rembourse les
rémunérations des personnels que
effectivement mises à disposition
parallèlement l'état s'engage dans la
convention triennale
à verser à la maison départementale une
subvention de fonctionnement qui doit
couvrir au minimum les montants
remboursés par les mdp à ce titre des
rémunérations des personnels mise à
disposition et à intégrer une
contribution aux frais généraux en cas
de vacance de poste
la mdph disposera alors de moyens
financiers pour embaucher des personnels
pour le pouvoir
dans ce schéma il faut annexé à cette
convention
un avenant financier annuel afin de
préciser le montant de la participation
des membres du gouvernement ainsi que
celui les concours versés par la cns à
au conseil général pour contribuer au
fonctionnement de la maison
départementale
vous le voyez la solution obtenue permet
ainsi de concilier tous les objectifs
que nous nous étions fixés stabilisation
des personnels et amélioration de leurs
perspectives de carrière garantie
financière et plus grande souplesse de
fonctionnement pour les mdph enfin
préservation du rôle de l'état dans les
politiques en faveur du handicap
j'en viens maintenant aux politiques en
faveur de l'emploi des personnes
handicapées
plusieurs éléments ont modifié
l'organisation de la gouvernance des
politiques en faveur de l'emploi des
personnes handicapées au cours des
dernières années la création du fonds
d'insertion des personnes handicapées
dans la fonction publique en 2005 et de
pôle emploi en 2008 mais aussi la
réforme de la hache qui prévoit
désormais que toute demande
renouvellement à la prestation sera
systématiquement assortie d'une
évaluation par la mdph des capacités
professionnelles la personne concernée
et d'une orientation il convenait d'en
tenir compte et de revenus définir et
clarifier dans ce nouveau cadre le rôle
des différents acteurs
le texte adopté par la commission
prévoit
la signature d'une convention entre
l'état et les acteurs concernés âgés fip
et filles ps le fond de la fonction
publique pôle emploi et la scène s a
assorti de décliner de déclinaisons
régionales et locales
associant les mdph et les cap emploi et
s'appuyant sur les plans régionaux
d'insertion professionnelle des
travailleurs handicapés
la réaffirmation de la place du service
public dans l'emploi et de l'état dans
le pilotage c'est politique la
définition légale des missions assignées
aux organismes de placements spécialisés
tels que les cap emploi qui ont démonté
leurs compétences spécifiques en termes
d'orientation de placement et de suivi
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées
la définition des modalités de
partenariat des mdph avait d autres
acteurs par ailleurs la commission a
adopté de mesures nouvelles la première
autorise le fond de la fonction publique
à financer des actions réalisées à son
initiative dans les trois fonctions
publiques et à subventionner des
organismes ou associations avaient
desquelles il a conclu une convention la
seconde modifie les critères
d'attribution des aides au poste aux
entreprises adaptées
je termine avec différence diverses
mesures tendant à améliorer la
compensation des conséquences du
handicap la première vise à renforcer la
prise en charge des aides humaines par
la prestation de compensation la
couverture des frais correspondants se
limitent actuellement aux seuls cas où
l'état de la personne handicapée
justifie dead d'une tierce personne pour
les actes essentiels d'existence heurter
une surveillance particulière
or la notion d' actes essentiels de
l'existence fait l'objet d'une
interprétation très restrictive qui
conduit en pratique à dissocier la prise
en charge de certaines aides domestiques
et leurs souliers
à titre d'exemple alors que l'aide à la
prise des repas est incluse dans le
périmètre de la pch leur préparation et
des tâches ménagères et qui suivent ne
le sont pas cette situation explique en
grande partie les réticences des
bénéficiaires de la ctp a opté pour la
pch
alors qu environ
trois mille personnes perçoivent la
nouvelle prestation 110000 ont choisi de
conserver l'ancien afin de rendre la pch
plus attractive le texte propose
d'élargir le périmètre de prise en
charge des aides humaines au cas où
celle-ci conditions de maintien à
domicile
je connais la réticence des conseils
généraux envers cette mesure qui
pourrait s'avérer coûteuse pour les
finances départementales encore que son
coup tu n'es pas été chiffrée mais j'ai
souhaité ouvrir le débat
la deuxième mesure prévoit la mise en
place en fin d'année d'un mécanisme de
péréquation des cons converser par la
scène et cela aux conseils généraux au
titre de la pch afin qu'ils soient mieux
ajuster aux dépenses qu'ils ont
réellement engagés
si dans un premier temps l'ensemble des
dépenses de la pch
on était deux largement couvertes par
ces concours du fait de la montée en
charge progressive la pch
en observant les maires ce depuis 2009
une dégradation du taux de couverture
pour l'ensemble des départements
mais les situations sont très diverses
d'un département à l'autre
l'objectif de caisse du texte est de
réduire ces écarts selon des modalités
définies par décret pris après avis du
conseil de la csa où sont représentés
les conseils généraux c'est une question
sensible qui mérite toute notre
attention
un groupe de travail se penche
actuellement sur la pertinence des
critères de répartition des convertis au
département qui ne semble pas très
adaptée alors que l'on observe une
dégradation inquiétante du taux de
couverture moyen annuel des dépenses de
pch qui devrait avoisiner 40% d'ici la
fin de 2010 j'admets que la question de
l'application puisse paraître secondaire
par rapport à celle de la compensation
réelle des dépenses dans ce contexte
pouvez vous nous dire madame la ministre
quelles sont les solutions envisagées
par le gouvernement pour trouver de
nouvelles sources de financement pour
les départements qui ne parviendront
plus à faire face à ses dépenses
croissantes
enfin la commission a adopté deux
mesures nouvelles relatives à
l'accessibilité la première favorise la
mise en accessibilité des constructions
neuves
en prévoyant des mesures de substitution
en cas d'impossibilité avérée de remplir
les exigences réglementaires ou légal la
seconde vise à étendre l'obligation
faite aux distributeurs de services adsl
le câble satellite d'offrir gratuitement
les prestations nécessaires à la
diffusion des programmes audiovisuels au
taux dé kyoto décrit destiné aux
personnes aveugles ou malvoyantes
comme vous le voyez cette proposition de
loi nous a permis de balayer tout le
champ des politiques en faveur du
handicap et de faire en quelque sorte un
audit de la loi du 11 février 2005
je crois que nous n'avons pas à rougir
des avancées que cette loi a permise
grâce à notre majorité bien au contraire
les améliorations que je vous repose sur
le fruit d'un travail approfondi des
coûte de concertation et d analyse elles
permettront je crois et je l'espère de
résoudre les difficultés que rencontrent
les mdph d'offrir des garanties
supplémentaires aux conseils généraux
mais aussi de faire progresser la cause
des personnes handicapées et d'améliorer
leur quotidien
c'est en tout cas ce que je souhaite de
tout coeur je vous remercie
si monsieur le rapporteur la parole est
à madame nadine morano secrétaire d'état
chargée de la famille et de la
solidarité
madame la présidente mais madame da
président de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les maisons départementales
sont là des apports majeurs de la grande
loi du 11 février 2005
avec elle nous avons créé un lieu de
proximité permettant d'éviter ce fameux
parcours du combattant auquel est
confronté celui ou celle qui rencontre
le handicap une famille également qu'ils
rencontrent à travers son enfant le
handicap
mais si les maisons départementales se
sont progressivement mises en place sous
l'égide des conseils généraux leur
situation
c'est vrai reste variable selon les
départements et certains points communs
de fonctionnement ou de
dysfonctionnements se sont rapidement
fait jour fort de ce constat le
président de la république à l'occasion
de la conférence nationale du handicap a
affirmé qu'il fallait améliorer le
fonctionnement des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées pour que tout soit enfin à
la hauteur des attentes des familles
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette optique
monsieur le rapporteur que le 24 juin
vous avez remis avec madame le sénateur
annie jarraud vergnolle un rapport
d'information sur le bilan des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées
votre proposition de loi fait suite à ce
rapport
il suggère plusieurs solutions aux
difficultés constatées et propose plus
largement certaines améliorations à la
loi du 11 février 2005 avant d'en
détailler les différents aspects je
souhaite naturellement remercié le
sénateur paul blanc son remarquable
travail
s'agissant du statut des personnels des
mdph d'abord en préambule je veux
rappeler que l'état a largement
contribué aux mdph en apportant du
personnel ou en le compensant quand ces
personnes quitter pour une raison ou une
autre la mdph
en 2009 15 points 8 millions d'euros ont
ainsi été versés
pour compenser les postes vacants et
25,4 millions d'euros de subventions de
fonctionnement du haut mdph ont été
déléguées la loi de finances pour 2010 a
prévu la compensation de ces postes
pour cette année 2010 un point précis
des postes occupés est vacant au 1er
janvier dans les mdph est en train
d'être réalisé il servira de base à un
dialogue de gestion locale c'est tout
l'objet de la circulaire du 14 avril
2010 mais ce n'est pas tout le
gouvernement a veillé à ce que la cei
nsa pérennise son concours financiers
aux mdph hauteur de 60 millions d'euros
l'efmd ph rencontrent des difficultés de
fonctionnement notamment en raison de
l'absence de stabilisation des équipes
c'est le point important que vous aviez
souligné monsieur le rapporteur le
membre
les membres du personnel en effet relève
actuellement d'une multitude de statut
fonctionnaire mis à la disposition par
l'état où le conseil général personnels
de droit public ou privé agents détachés
de sorte qu'il est difficile de mettre
en place une gestion des ressources
humaines dignes de ce nom en particulier
les personnels de l'état mis à
disposition des mdph ont la possibilité
de réintégrer leur administration
d'origine avec une simple condition de
préavis de trois mois
aujourd'hui près de 600 postes d'agents
de l'état sur 1600 sont vacants le
gouvernement partage donc pleinement
votre objectif qui est de garantir une
plus grande stabilité des personnels il
se félicite du maintien du mécanisme de
la mise à disposition a duré a sorti par
nom d'une durée de préavis plus longue
est de mise à disposition plus longue
surtout cette mise à disposition sera
remboursé via un mécanisme de double
financement de l'état puisque la mdph
touchera en début d'année une subvention
annuelle qui lui permettra soit de
recruter sans délai si l'agent est parti
laissant son poste vacant
soit de rembourser l'état en fin d'année
pour l'argent mais pour l'agent pardon
mis à disposition ce mécanisme garantira
aux mdph la visibilité financière dont
elles ont tant besoin pour être à la
hauteur des missions qui leur sont
confiées
le deuxième point que je veux aborder
c'est le fonctionnement des mdph
le gouvernement salue votre proposition
de consolider le statut des mdph en
faisant du groupe d'intérêt public une
structure à durée indéterminée
nous accueillons aussi très
favorablement la participation du
directeur général de la rs aux
commissions exécutives
cette présence au sein de l'organe de
décision et d'organisation de la mdph va
permettre aux mdph d'avoir une approche
plus transversale et améliorer
l'articulation des mdph et des
établissements hospitaliers
les mesures de simplification
constituent d'autres avancées
substantielles
je pense à la clarification des
compétences territoriales qui va
supprimer toute guerre des frontières à
l'harmonisation du contentieux
je pense également la possibilité pour
la commission des droits et de
l'autonomie de statuer en formation
restreinte au sein des commissions
spécialisées ou locales elle reprend une
proposition que la scène et ça allait
formuler en juillet 2007
cette simplification va permettre qu'un
plus grand nombre de dossiers soit
effectivement étudié par les commissions
j'ajoute que la commission plénière
pourra ainsi le cas échéant devenir
l'instance de régulation entre ses
sous-commissions j'en viens au
dispositif d'insertion professionnelle
ce texte opère plusieurs clarifications
utile je retiendrai trois en premier
lieu ils réaffirment le rôle de l'état
dans le pilotage de la politique de
l'emploi des personnes handicapées qui
fait intervenir une pluralité d'acteurs
et renforce sa gouvernance de cette
politique
une convention cadre pluriannuel
d'objectifs et de moyens sera conclue
entre l'état pôle emploi
le fph ft l'agefiph et la seleçao et
sera décliné en convention régionale
deuxième clarification bienvenus ce
texte élargit le champ des bénéficiaires
potentiels des aides financières du fph
ft et donne à ce dernier la capacité
d'initiative qui lui faisait défaut
désormais le fph fp pourra subventionner
des organismes et associations qui
contribuent à l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées dans la fonction publique
avec lesquels il aura passé une
convention
même si les derniers n'ont pas la
qualité d'employeur public
cet assouplissement du cadre juridique
et était unanimement souhaité par
l'ensemble des acteurs
il permettra au fonds de développer plus
largement ses actions en faveur de
l'insertion des personnes handicapées
dans la fonction publique
cette proposition de loi et c'est le
troisième point clarifie les critères
pris en compte pour le versement aux
entreprises adaptées au centre de
distribution par le travail des aides
financières qui leur sont destinés ces
entreprises jouent un rôle essentiel
dans l'insertion des personnes
handicapées puisque 80% de leurs
salariés sont des travailleurs
handicapés
là aussi il s'agit d'une clarification
et d'une simplification qui était très
attendue par les professionnels du
secteur
en ce qui concerne la compensation du
handicap
la prestation de compensation du
handicap a considérablement améliorer la
couverture des besoins de compensation
des personnes handicapées l'extension de
la prestation de compensation aux aides
ménagères est une revendication
récurrente des personnes handicapées
mais pour cela c'est l'ensemble des
prestations qui doit être examinée est
non seulement une partie le tout
en tenant compte des contraintes des
finances publiques et plus
particulièrement de celles les
départements je vous rappelle que le
coût pour les conseils généraux pourrait
dépasser plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros
or la fiscalité locale à d'ores et déjà
augmenté de 8,1 pour cent en 2009 et
même de 11% pour certains départements
en ce qui concerne les concours de la
scène et ça pour la pch vous proposer
l'introduction d'un dispositif de
péréquation des concours départementaux
de la scène et ça pour ramener un taux
moyen
les taux de couverture de la dépendance
qui sont très disparates
cette disposition relève je vous le dis
à mon sens de la fausse bonne idée
j'y reviendrai lorsque nous examinerons
l'article 14
d'abord elle présente un risque majeur
mettre en place un mécanisme automatique
de péréquation et risque d'être brutal
et mal interprétés par certains
départements qui ont encore un fort taux
de bénéficiaires de l'allocation tierce
personne que la pch a remplacé mais qui
demeure pour les bénéficiaires
antérieurement à 2005
en outre il est indispensable d'attendre
les conclusions du groupe de travail du
président de la cnse à francis idrac qui
travaille actuellement sur les critères
de péréquation entre les départements il
faut rechercher une résolution globale à
cette question qui englobe non seulement
les concours pch mais également les
concours à part en résumé un sujet d'une
telle ampleur tant politique que
financière ne peut selon le gouvernement
être abordés au cours de cette
proposition de loi
je terminerai par la politique
d'accessibilité
en ce qui concerne la meilleure
participation à la vie de la cité pour
nous citoyens handicapés
le gouvernement a pris ses
responsabilités le temps presse nous
savons transport lieux publics magasins
dans cinq ans au 1er janvier 2015 toutes
les villes
devront être accessibles aux personnes
handicapées c'est un chantier titanesque
pour le conduire
nous avons créé l'observatoire
interministériel de l'accessibilité et
de la conception universelle
présidée par votre collègue sylvie
desmarescaux l'accessibilité ne concerne
pas que les handicapés moteurs
il ne faut pas penser non plus
uniquement au cadre baki j'en viens à
l'accessibilité des logements neufs là
encore la loi de 2005 a posé des
exigences très claire dès 2006 tous les
partenaires y compris les associations
de personnes handicapées avaient acté le
fait qu'il pourrait y avoir des
dérogations
ce mot est difficilement acceptable je
le conçois nous parlerons désormais de
mesures de substitution
il n'est pas question de ne pas rendre
accessible mais de rendre accessible
autrement je serai intransigeant
là dessus je sais combien ce sujet vous
tient à coeur et je vous soutiendrai
dans vos démarches en faveur d'une cité
qui soit entièrement accessible pour nos
citoyens handicapés mais je souhaite
néanmoins attirer votre attention sur
une chose
à trop vouloir imposer des règles
strictes
on risque en fait de paralyser le
système tout entier
notre pays a aussi besoin de résidences
de tourisme
il a plus besoin encore de logements
sociaux nous devons répondre aux besoins
des français et de tous les français
à cet égard ge dans la tête ces
aménagements sont indispensables à une
approche pragmatique de l'accessibilité
en conclusion l'examen de cette
proposition de loi montre s'il en est
besoin combien la représentation
nationale adhère à la volonté du
président de la république et fait une
priorité de la pleine intégration des
personnes handicapées dans notre société
je vous remercie une fois encore pour
tout le travail accompli cette matinée
est une occasion supplémentaire donnée
aux personnes handicapées d'être une
fois encore sur le devant de la scène
et de faire entendre leur voix de faire
valoir leurs intérêts la maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
est une réponse symbolique forte qui
veut témoigner de notre volonté de
proposer un lieu où les personnes
handicapées et leurs familles ne se
sentiront plus jamais oublié ou
prisonnière de fonctionnement
administratif
avec ce texte vous nous signifier que du
chemin reste à parcourir pour garantir
ce résultat mais vous nous signifier
également que cet authentique
intégration dans la société des
personnes handicapées est possible qu'il
suffit de la vouloir qu'il suffit de la
faire
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame jarraud vergnolle
au titre du groupe socialiste
merci monsieur donc la loi du 11 février
2005 a créé dans chaque département un
lieu unique destiné à faciliter les
démarches des personnes handicapées quel
que soit leur âge leur situation
personnelle et professionnelle et à leur
offrir un accès unifié aux droits et
prestations prévues à leur égard
les mdp à assen juridiquement le jour à
partir de 2006 ils ont été opérationnels
dans tous les départements en 2007 donc
constituer en groupement d'intérêt
public est placé sous la tutelle
administrative et financière des
conseils généraux elle regroupe les
associations d'usagers
les partenaires du handicap et l'état
qui de par sa présence doit garantir une
certaine équité territoriale entre les
départements amené à se substituer aux
cds et cotorep
elles ont dû récupérer les personnels
d'état leur étant affectées alertée
depuis début 2009 par les associations
d'usagers sur les dysfonctionnements de
certaines mdph
nous avons décidé avec paul blonde
effectué une mission d'information
travail que nous avons rendu public fin
fin juin 2009 tendon ce rapport mettait
en exergue un certain nombre d'éléments
déstabilisateur qu'ils n'avaient pas été
prévus lors de la création des mdph
tout d'abord la majorité des dirigeants
de par leur dynamisme essayé tant bien
que mal de structurer leur mdph malgré
un héritage lourd dossier
ensuite l'instabilité des personnels
d'état et la diversité des statuts
entraîné les difficultés de gestion des
ressources humaines d'établissement de
rythmes de travail de mise en place de
formations
enfin l'insuffisance de garanties de
financement tant dans la non
compensation des postes état devenu
vacances surtout en 2008 et 2009 que du
manque de trésorerie rang des situations
des mdph de plus en plus précaire
globalement notre rapport d'information
sur le fonctionnement des mdph rappeler
à l'état ses obligations en soulignant
que l'apurement de ses dettes et le
respect de ces engagements étaient une
condition indispensable au bon
fonctionnement des mdph
aujourd'hui cette ppl reprend en partie
des conclu
on est préconisations du rapport le
gouvernement va-t-il s'en saisir j'en
doute
madame la ministre si vous le permettez
je vous citerai en matière de handicap
il ya ceux qui parlent et ceux qui
agissent or depuis un an que le rapport
dont vous avez d'ailleurs relevé la
pertinence est publié rien de concret
n'a évolué et nous en avons encore
aujourd'hui la démonstration car les
difficultés des mdph vont crescendo
au point que certaines d'entre elles
sont au bord du dépôt de bilan
déjà il y à plus d'un an la ds alerter
l'opinion en lançant un cri d'alarmé les
mdph sont tendances y est sans danger
certainement devoir fermer fin 2009
l'association des directeurs en des
publics leur seconde enquête très
explicite
en effet la secte ation des crédits a
lancé 10 millions d'euros tant au second
semestre 2008 par valérie létard pour
financer les charges non compensés de
cette même année que l' annonce faite
par vous même madame la ministre sur la
même enveloppe mais qui concerne en
réalité l'exercice 2009
sans prendre en compte l'antériorité des
dettes cumulées montre bien le
désengagement de l'état vis-à-vis de sa
dette
car seuls 3,7 millions sur dix ont bien
atteint leur objectif de compensation en
cette enquête réalisée entre le 1er
septembre et 13 octobre 2009 permettait
de mesurer le besoin total de crédits
nécessaires au ministère du travail des
relations sociales de la solidarité de
la famille de la ville pour apurer
l'intégralité de la dette d'état des
deux tiers des mdph
ils y ont répandu la dette de l'état sur
les postes vacants depuis la création
des mdph a été a évalué à 19 3 millions
d'euros somme à laquelle il faut ajouter
la dette cumulée résiduelles au titre de
la fongibilité asymétrique est de
l'ordre de 15 millions d'euros
ainsi c'est un budget de 34 3 millions
d'euros que l'état se doit d'affecter au
plus tôt aux mdph cette somme paraît
colossal et pourtant
à titre d'exemple ce désengagement de
l'état vis-à-vis des mdph ne représente
que 5,1 pour cent des exonérations
sociales et fiscales
des heures supplémentaires du seul
premier trimestre 2010 jusqu'à présent
les conseils généraux ont accepté de se
substituer provisoirement à l'état pour
financer ces postes afin de garantir la
continuité du service public mais le
resserrement brutal des budgets des
conseils généraux risque probablement de
mettre à mal leur capacité à maintenir
les avances budgétaire et même à les
augmenter en raison de l'accroissement
du phénomène
il devient donc urgent de trouver une
solution de compensation pour les
exercices passés l'exercice en cours et
surtout l'avenir car il n'est pas
envisageable que la première résolution
durable du problème donc la résolution
durable du problème soit renvoyée à la
loi sur le cinquième risque et
l'évolution des missions md phd à
présent c'est le fonctionnement même des
mdph qui présentent un risque fort
d'ailleurs plusieurs contentieux sont
actuellement en cours
les mdph des ardennes du finistère de
seine et marne de paris ont déposé
plainte contre l'état devant le tribunal
administratif et bien d'autres risquent
de leur emboîter le pas c'est pourquoi
en présupposant que l'état et la volonté
de mobiliser les moyens adaptés
une démarche méthodologique est à mettre
en place car effectivement le montage
actuellement pour le financement des
postes d'état ne peut perdurer et la
situation s'aggrave d'année en année
aujourd'hui ce sont plus de 600 postes
si vous l'avez dit qu'ils sont devenus
vacants votre circulaire 2010 109 du 14
avril 2010 est paru la semaine dernière
au bo santé protection sociale
solidarité
quelques jours avant ce débat dans
l'hémicycle relatives à la compensation
des postes devenus vacants dans les mdph
à la suite de retour dans les services
de l'état elle propose aux ministères
concernés d'établir un diagnostic
partagé sur la situation des personnels
de l'état dans les mdph afin de
compenser financièrement en 2010
l'ensemble des postes vacants par contre
il n'est nullement fait référence au non
compensation des années antérieures et
notamment celle de l'année 2008
que comptez-vous faire madame la
ministre dans les directeurs des mdph
que les associations personnes
handicapées attendent
qu'enfin le gouvernement remplit ses
engagements au moins
heureusement fidèles rapport
d'information que nous avons réalisés
l'an dernier cette ppl a le mérite de
proposer pour l'avenir les solutions
visant à stabiliser les salariés des
mdph à les former et enrichir leurs
perspectives de carrière au travers de
conventions triennales dans lesquelles
l'état s'engage à transférer les moyens
nécessaires au remplacement de toute
défection des fonctionnaires de l'état
le titre est donc conforme aux
propositions que nous avions émises
quant au titre 2 relatives à la
politique du handicap nous émettrons un
certain nombre de réserves
l'organisation et la gouvernance des
politiques d'insertion professionnelle
des personnes handicapées ont évolué ces
dernières années avec la création du sip
hsp la mise en place du pôle emploi la
réforme de l'âge dont l'attribution est
d est dorénavant conditionnée à une
évaluation des capacités
professionnelles du demandeur
réalisé par les mdph outre ces
bouleversements substantielle
nécessitant une adaptation permanente
des acteurs avec un surcroît de travail
nous avions alerté en 2008 valérie
létard sur la notion d'un possibilité de
se procurer un emploi notion pénalisante
pour les personnes ayant un taux de
handicap compris entre 50 et 79 % qui
soit souhaitait demander une à l'article
l821 2 du code de la sécurité sociale
prévoit maintenant que le handicap subi
doit être entraîner une restriction
substantielle et durable pour l'accès à
l'emploi et n'exige plus que la personne
handicapée n'est pas exercé d'activité
pendant un an avant la demande
ces modifications votées dans la loi de
finances fin 2008 ne peuvent cependant
être appliquée car le décret prévu par
la loi pour définir cette nouvelle
notion n'est toujours pas paru
par contre nous sommes tout à fait
favorables aux dispositions prévues dans
cette ppl avec le rapprochement et la
mutualisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
de l'emploi pôle emploi le réseau des
cap emploi les pmi thérage même si nous
regrettons les pays th outil de
proximité mais aussi l'étalagé fip
fiphp les services de placement
spécialisée dans l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées comme le préconise le
rapport busnel cependant le point faible
demeure toujours la formation car 83%
des personnes handicapées ont un niveau
scolaire inférieur au niveau bac
de même les esat et entreprises adaptées
sont en nombre insuffisant avec des
listes d'attentes sur plusieurs années
et des soucis de pérennité de
financement un autre problème criant et
celui qui se pose également
lors des décisions d'orientation
scolaire qui représente près de 40% des
demandes enfants à la cdaph et font
l'objet d'un projet personnalisé de
scolarisation qui doit être évaluée
chaque année mais ces décisions se
heurte souvent à un nombre insuffisant
de places disponibles dans les
établissements spécialisés mais aussi à
la difficulté de trouver des auxiliaires
de vie scolaire or dorénavant un certain
nombre de contentieux voit le jour le 4
juin 2010 le tribunal administratif de
pau a tranché en faveur de cette famille
d'enfants handicapés et a condamné le
ministère de l'éducation nationale à
revoir son refus implicite d'attribuer
des avs à leurs enfants et à payer 300
euros à chaque famille pour les frais de
procédure
la précarité l'absence de formation et
le turnover fréquence des emplois avs ne
sont pas propices à une bonne
intégration scolaire des enfants
handicapés
malgré la promesse de luc chatel dans sa
déclaration du 15 septembre 2009 de
reconduire les 5000 postes d'avs et
est-ce arrivé en fin de contrat au
travers d'une convention iv la réalité
est tout autre
la reconduction des contrats a permis
seulement de pérenniser 130 postes d'avs
et s une fois de plus des paroles non
suivies d'effets le ministère de
l'éducation nationale vient de signer de
nouvelles conventions cadres une avec
les quatre associations représentatives
des personnes handicapées et la seconde
avec les services d'aidé et
d'accompagnement à domicile
quelle est leur contenu prévoit-elle une
professionnalisation des métiers de
l'accompagnement
envisage-t-elle de conforter les emplois
avs quant aux mesures de substitution
aux règles de mise en accessibilité du
bâti neuf
je regrette sincèrement que le
rapporteur s'engage sur une voie en
contradiction avec l'esprit de la loi de
il est vrai que le gouvernement a tenté
à plusieurs reprises d'étendre les
possibilités de dérogations pour les
constructions de bâtiments neufs
heureusement le conseil constitutionnel
a censuré l'article en cause dans la loi
de finances rectificative de 2009
nous traiterons les autres points
contenus dans ce texte et notamment la
pch qu'abordera mon collègue il dolynny
lors du débat sur amendement
nous regrettons cependant compte tenu
des enjeux et de l'importance de cette
ppl qu'elle était été retardé à
plusieurs reprises et qu'elle soit
discutée dans un laps de temps qui ne
favorise pas les échanges
décidément le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que l'initiative parlementaire est
encore une fois vilipendé merci chaque
collègue yves la parole est à madame
anne marie escoffier au titre du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
s'il est une loi qui a fait la quasi
unanimité sur tous les bancs de cette
haute assemblée du moins dans ses
principes souvient la loi du 11 février
2005 pour l'égalité des droits et des
chances la participation et la
citoyenneté des personnes handicapées
elle a en particulier a institué la
création des maisons départementales des
personnes handicapées forme de guichet
unique ayant pour objectif premier de
faciliter les démarches de ces personnes
et d'éviter de fragiliser encore
davantage des personnes qui ont besoin
d'une aide privilégiée dans leur vie
quotidienne
la proposition de loi vient heureusement
faire le bilan de ce dispositif et à la
lumière de ce constat à partait quelques
aménage
moi je voudrais d'abord évoqué justement
le constat que l'on peut être que l'on
peut faire sur le fonctionnement de ces
maisons je relève des points forts un
dispositif qui veut être un dispositif
de cohérence cohérence entre les
différents partenaires qui se rejoignent
dans leur action
l'état les collectivités locales le
conseil général tout particulièrement
l'éducation nationale mais tous les
autres services de l'état concourent
ensemble au bon fonctionnement de cette
maison départementale des personnes
handicapées
c'est une maison départementale
clairement identifiés par les personnes
handicapées je crois que sur ce point
c'est tout à fait essentiel que l'on
sache dans un département dans une ville
où se trouve le lieu commun où l'on peut
aller trouver une aide
je souligne aussi dans les points forts
la forme juridique du gip et de ce
groupement d'intérêt public qui a été
adopté par quasiment toutes les maisons
départementales et qui aujourd'hui le
réclament
c'est un point tout à fait intéressant
d'autant que l'on en a fait aujourd'hui
un groupement un groupement à durée
indéterminée c'est un lieu donc où
l'ensemble des intervenants pourront se
retrouver chacun apportant sa quote-part
troisième point fort l'enrichissement
des métiers et là j'y tiens beaucoup
il se trouve que les maisons du handicap
sont des lieux où se réunit l'ensemble
des personnes qui à un titre ou un autre
ont eu à connaître
honte à connaître de la situation des
personnels handicapés et il est clair
que leur expérience leur richesse vient
conforter l'examen que l'on peut faire
de la situation des personnes les plus
fragiles c'est une véritable culture
partagée c'est une véritable capacité d'
expertise qui n'a pas d'équivalent
je veux le dire troisième point fort la
réduction du délai de traitement des
dossiers
pour ceux d'entre nous qui ont eu à
travailler avec les cotorep qui ont eu à
travailler avec les cds
nous savons ce que veut dire
adduction des délais c'est quelque chose
de quelque chose d'essentiel à laquelle
il nous fallait parvenir
c'était un objectif c'était un objectif
au total les points forts que je veux
relever c'est que effectivement les
maisons départementales des personnes
elle handicapée ont concouru à cette
efficience mais au delà de l'efficience
parce qu'elle ne peut pas être
simplement comptable à une véritable
humanisation du dispositif et à une
véritable proximité de la personne
handicapée
vous me permettrez quand même madame le
ministre de soulever un certain nombre
de points faibles
les personnels d'abord les personnels on
l'a vécu statuts différents rythmes de
congés différents horaires complexe
remplacement non opéré quand il ya eu
des départs qui ont pu être spontané et
un peu trop rapide
pas de compensation financière c'est un
point sur lequel les départements sont
tous intervenus
je rappelle aussi un certain nombre de
postes non pourvus
et tout cela a conduit inexorablement au
retard dans l'examen des dossiers c'est
dire que l'objectif recherché
tout d'un coup c'est trouver
complètement anéanti les financements
chacun d'entre nous ici en a parlé les
financements sont très en deçà des
engagements pris par l'état présent de
ça je dis simplement un chiffre pour mon
département de l'aveyron trois cent
mille euros qui aujourd'hui nous
attendons et dont nous ne savons pas
comment nous allons les obtenir
et quand nous allons les obtenir les
dettes sont des dates qui sont cumulées
depuis plusieurs années manama ministre
et les chiffres que vous avez donné
s'ils sont bien réels ne tiennent pas
compte de ce cumul
je voudrais aussi évoqué cette
prestation de compensation du handicap
qui certes dans sa totalité ne vient pas
compensé l'allocation compensatrice pour
tierce personne
quel équilibre comment et
parviendrons-nous quels seront les
sources de financement pour la face à
ses points forts mais à ses points
faibles aussi madame la ministre
il y à des mesures qui ont été proposées
et dont je voudrais saluer la qualité
elles vont dans le bon sens
stabilisation des personnels c'est vrai
mais permettez moi permettez moi de dire
ne risquons nous pas une perte de la
mémoire collective un appauvrissement du
métier en en allant vers une unification
une homogénéisation des personnels
même si statutairement il y à une
amélioration notamment en matière de
formation
on risque de perles à une qualité de
l'expérience
monsieur le rapporteur je vous remercie
de vinay du bonnet s'agissant du
financement
il y a certes une convention 8 opiné du
bonnet il y à une convention
pluriannuelle qui est qui va être conclu
avec une convention d'objectifs et de
moyens je me sens là complètement
intégrée à la palabre problématique de
la lolf
oui mais c'est bien effectivement
d'avoir des objectifs d'un voire des
moyens encore faut-il pouvoir les
évaluer et s'assurer très régulièrement
que tout cela est mis en oeuvre
or madame la ministre permettez moi de
dire que la défaillance de l'état je ne
parlerai pas du désengagement c'est un
mot que je n'utilise pas que fait pas
partie de mon vocabulaire
mesila l'état s'est trouvé être
défaillant en plusieurs occasions
comment demain sera-t-il sanctionné
il me semble que le texte ne prévoie pas
de mesures obligeant l'état à payer ses
dettes
voilà je voudrais enfin terminée sûr
mais très très rapidement sur les
problèmes de gouvernance des personnes
handicapées une difficulté me semble
t'il vous l'avez dit madame la ministre
il faut que nous soyons dans un système
de proximité qui préserve l'individu la
proximité aujourd'hui va se trouver
transporté au niveau régional l'état
s'est organisée au niveau régional alors
pilotage de l'état assurément mais un
état qui pas su faire lointain je crois
qu'il faut que nous veillions avec une
particulière
assiduité à ce que nous restions très
près de ses personnels handicapés à qui
nous devons tout notre intérêt
merci madame 1 la parole est à madame
isabelle pasquet au titre du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen sénateurs
du parti de gauche
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il a plus de cinq
ans notre pays se doter d'une loi dont
la volonté était selon les propres
termes du président de la république
d'alors jacques chirac de réunir les
conditions pour que les personnes
handicapées puissent vivre leur vie et
l'air et la réussir cinq ans après si
les choses ont quelque peu évolué
notamment grâce à l'implication
régulière et continue des associations
de personnes handicapées et de leurs
familles ainsi que des l'immense
majorité des départements
un important travail reste à faire
notre société n'a pas contrairement aux
espoirs que nous portions tous dans la
loi de 2005 changer de regard sur le
handicap et sur les personnes qui le
vivent un important travail
d'information de formation
professionnelle et citoyenne de
s'ensabler sensibilisation reste à faire
cela exige clairement la mobilisation de
tous les acteurs publics pour que le
travail mené par le secteur associatif
soit valorisée et pour qu'enfin l'on
reconnaisse les personnes handicapées
dans leur antre dans l'intégralité de
leurs droits
qu'enfin nous fassions en sorte qu'elles
et ils trouvent leur place dans la
société
nous aurions d'ailleurs tous à y gagner
et pour reprendre la formule du
président de la fédération de la patte d
a pas que j'ai déjà utilisé ici lors du
débat que nous avons eu sur le bilan de
la loi du 11 février 2005
à chaque fois qu'on améliore les choses
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap
cela sert à toute la société à chaque
fois que l'on intégrable dans un
bâtiment une rampe d'accès on ne
facilite pas seulement la vie des
personnes en situation de handicap
on facilite aussi celle de la mère ou du
père de famille qui sort ses enfants
poussettes ou celle de la personne âgée
qui peinent à monter les mars en pensant
immédiatement dès la phase de
construction à l'accessibilité pour tous
on prépare en fait notre pays aux
mutations sociologiques qui se profile à
cet égard nous ne pouvons qu être posée
monsieur le sénateur paul blanc à
l'article additionnel après l'article 14
que vous avez vous même inséré par voie
d'amendement
en commission il s'agit ni plus ni moins
pour reprendre la formulation utilisée
par la fnath et la pf d'un chèque en
blanc pour les prometteurs et les lobbys
j'ai l'impression pour être franc ce que
cette disposition constitue pour vous
une sorte de consensus entre les
obligations imposées par la loi et les
pressions des différents groupes de
pression cela n'en est pour autant pas
plus acceptable car les personnes en
situation de handicap qui ne parviennent
pas à se loger ou qui ne réunissent pas
qu'ils ne réussissent pas à gravir les
mars ne font pas de consensus
avec leur handicap et ce d'autant plus
que se rajoute à leur handicap des
situations de surendettement que nous
pouvons pourtant de par nos actions
limitées monsieur les sénateurs notre
groupe a déposé un amendement de
suppression de cette disposition qui je
l'espère trouvera votre assentiment et
recueillera la majorité des votes
à défaut si cet article additionnel
après l'article xiv était maintenu
nous n'aurions pas d'autre choix que de
voter contre l'ensemble de votre
proposition de loi je le regrette
sincèrement et ce d'autant que d'autant
plus que nous étions prêts à soutenir
certaines de vos propositions
je pense en particulier à celles
concernant les maisons départementales
des personnes handicapées
nous partageons votre souci qui prend
forme d'un autre article le premier de
pérenniser le statut des mdph le choix
que vous avez retenu nous semble être le
meilleur
la structure actuelle permet
l'association de la pluralité des
acteurs ce qui ce qui incontestablement
est un gage de qualité par ailleurs elle
permet dans la théorie du moins de
garantir l'aspect national de la
politique du handicap
à ce titre je voudrais dire notre
opposition à la tentation que certains
pourraient avoir d'intégrer les mdph
dans les services des conseils généraux
le fait que les départements supplée
trop souvent l'état particulièrement au
plan financier ne doit pas servir
d'arguments pour une telle intégration
nous ne devons pas partir du constat
d'une anomalie pour adopter des mesures
qui auraient pour effet de décentraliser
complètement la politique du handicap et
de rompre avec le principe de la
solidarité nationale
toutefois il faudra bien que le
financement des mdph soit assurée de
manière pérenne
ce qui est loin d'être actuellement le
cas car la compensation financière
promise par l'état en 2005 au titre des
emplois nos mis à disposition par ces
directions départementales n'a pas
toujours été assurée et selon une
enquête réalisée par l'association des
directeurs de maisons départementales
des personnes handicapées
la dette cumulée du cumulé de l'état à
l'égard de l'ensemble des mdph serait de
34 millions d'euros certaines d'entre
elles ont engagé des recours alors à
l'encontre de l'état cette
judiciarisation de notre système de
solidarité n'est pas souhaitable et
l'état devrait prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour qu'il s'applique à
lui-même les lois qu'ils décident
l'étoile doit éviter que ne se
multiplier les contentieux à l'image de
celui entamé par le département de saône
et loire est gagné par lui obligeant
l'état à créer abonder le fonds de
protection de l'enfance
les départements qui connaissent des
situations financières intenable ne
peuvent supporter seule l'absence de
financement de l'état
et ce d'autant plus que le gouvernement
et la majorité ont décidé de tarir les
ressources des conseils généraux et que
nicolas sarkozy comme françois fillon
disent vouloir appliquer aux
collectivités locales la politique de
rigueur qui mène au plan national
mais comment feront ils demain ces
départements dans le président du cdh a
dit lui-même qui sont en situation de
faillite pour continuer à payer toutes
les prestations sociales
individualiser la paix à pch rsa qui
tendent à s'accroître
enfin pour conclure je voudrais dire
quelques mots sur un sujet qui nous
préoccupe particulièrement et qui
malheureusement n'est pas abordée dans
cette proposition de loi il s'agit de la
scolarisation des enfants handicapés
nous avons pris acte de la signature par
cinq associations nationales d'un accord
quant à la reprise par leurs soins des
auxiliaires de vie de vie scolaire il
faut dire que la précédente convention
avait été dénoncé par l'ensemble des
signataires face au bout double constat
de l'impossibilité de déboucher sur une
définition du métier d'auxiliaire de vie
scolaire mais aussi sur la question du
financement particulièrement tout ce qui
relève des temps extra et périscolaire
cette situation ne peut nous satisfaire
cas beaucoup trop paix précaire
elle repose sur la capacité des
associations et sur le respect par
l'état des engagements financiers qu'il
a pris à leur égard cette situation de
substitution de l'état par le secteur
associatif marque une nouvelle fois la
des responsabilité des pouvoirs publics
et ce d'autant plus que les associations
y compris signataires de cette nouvelle
convention ont fait savoir qu'elles
regrettaient à la fois la précipitation
dans laquelle elle a été conclue
notamment l'absence de sollicitations du
conseil national caution consultatif des
personnes handicapées et du comité
national de l'organisation sociale et
sanitaire ainsi que le manque de
garanties quant au financement
nous considérons qu'une solution
nationale permettant d'associer
pleinement le ministère de l'éducation
nationale et d'autres comme celui du
travail et de la solidarité est possible
nous avions même cru que le report de
l'examen de votre ppl avait précisément
pour objectif d'intégrer cette question
capitale
hélas tel n'est pas le cas c'est
pourquoi monsieur le sénateur malgré les
quelques mesures que nous soutiendrons
nous serons contraints en raison des
absences que je viens de mentionner
surtout des dérogations relatives à
l'accessibilité au bâti que vous
renforcez de voter contre votre ppl
merci mme asha collègues
la parole est un monsieur jean jacques
pignard au titre de l'union centriste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues de 12 mai dernier nous
étions invités à faire le point sur la
loi handicap du 11 février 2005
cinq ans après sa promulgation ce débat
a permis à l'or de pointer les
dysfonctionnements les attentes non
satisfaites les frustrations l'attend
la proposition de loi qui nous est
soumise aujourd'hui reprend certaines
répondent à certaines des questions
posées alors elle s'inscrit bien sûr
dans les conclusions du rapport de 2009
cette proposition de loi constitue à
n'en pas douter une avancée
significative dont le mérite revient aux
rapporteurs notre collègue paul blanc et
à tous ceux qui avec lui au sein de la
commission des affaires sociales on
travaillait effectivement sur ce texte
le groupe de l'union centriste en prend
acte et participera de façon
constructive à la discussion dans le
temps qui m'est imparti
je privilégierai certains points qui
nous paraissent essentiels quitte à
revenir ensuite sur les autres dans le
cas de la discussion
si mais l'amélioration des maisons
départementales du fonctionnement des
maisons départementales des personnes
handicapées constituent l'objet
principal du texte celui ci intègre
aussi d'autres dispositions que
j'évoquerai à la fin de mon propos le
fonctionnement des mdph
c'est orthez nous avons tous dit à trois
types de difficultés les lourdeurs
administratives
l'insuffisance des garanties à court
terme sur les moyens financiers dont
elle dispose
l'instabilité de leur personnel liées à
la diversité des statuts lourdeurs
administratives
le constat établi que les délais
d'instruction sont en moyenne de 4 mois
conforme à la loi ne doit pas occulter
les importantes disparités constatées
dans les départements
l'allègement la simplification la
rationalisation des procédures prévues
dans le texte
devrait à coup sûr réduire ses délais et
résorber surtout les stocks accumulés au
grand bénéfice des usagers garanties
financières
c'est dans ce domaine que la proposition
de loi est la plus ambitieuse et si vous
me permettez monsieur le rapporteur la
plus astucieuse jusqu'à ce jour l'état
s'engageait à verser x équivalents temps
plein aux mdph et si hypothèse d'école
madame la ministre
l'état ne remplissait pas la totalité de
ses engagements par suite de retour des
personnels de leur corps d'origine
il était censé compenser ce manque par
une subvention a posteriori les mdp as
subi c'est donc en quelque sorte une
double peine elle manquait tout à la
fois de moyens humains en fait de
personnel et financier puisque la
compensation se faisait longuement
attendre lorsqu'elle venait avec le
mécanisme imaginé
l'état s'engage à verser une subvention
équivalente aux rémunérations des hauts
tp qu'il fournit et les mdph ne
rembourseront en fin d'année que
l'équivalent des salaires versés
effectivement au personnel présent le
tout sanctuarisée dans une convention
triennale
bref c'est l'état ne fournit pas des
personnels promis la mdph dispose au
moins a priori de l'argent nécessaire
pour embaucher d'autres types de
personnel
voilà qui devrait contribuer à réduire
les délais et à ne pas se heurter aux
vacances de personnel trop souvent
constatées
si sur ce point du financement le texte
est ambitieux nous regrettons qu'ils ne
soient un peu moins sur la question
pourtant essentielle des personnels dont
l'hétérogénéité des statuts est un frein
à l'efficacité du système
or la proposition de loi se contente de
formules plus ou moins homéopathie elle
pérennise le groupement d'intérêt public
soit c'est la volonté générale mais
aurait pu admettre des expérimentations
dans tel ou tel département
le connais c'est monsieur le rapporteur
vous connaissez aussi monsieur de vice
président je regrette que cela ne soit
pas possible
je regrette aussi que la première
mouture du texte n'ait pas été conservée
celle qui prévoyait une mise à
disposition des mdph des seuls
fonctionnaires territoriaux
elle aurait gagné certainement en
cohérence et en culture commune comme on
dit habituellement nous devons donc nous
satisfaire du compromis trouvé en
reconnaissant objectivement les progrès
sur deux points la mise à disposition
des personnels de l'état qui passerait
de 3 à 5 ans avec un préavis plus long
de six mois l'autorisation par le
groupement de recruter des agents
contrat de loire publics ou privés à
durée indéterminée cette disposition
offrira aux personnels des perspectives
de carrière au sein des mdph
nous saluons bien sûr également des
propositions concernant la formation des
personnels
quant à la gouvernance si nous nous
félicitons de la représentation des
agences régionales
certains de mes collègues se sont posé
la question de savoir si dans cette
hypothèse il fallait conserver sa place
au préfet ou à son représentant un
amendement avait même été proposé nous
l'avons retirée à la suite des arguments
développés en commission sur ce point
comme sur d'autres la diversité des
statuts continuera de faire le charme
des mdph
au delà du fonctionnement de ces maisons
le texte aborde d'autres points dont
deux sont au coeur des préoccupations
des personnes handicapées la
compensation et d'accessibilité
la compensation d'abord nous nous
félicitons de la mesure visant à mieux
prendre en compte les aides ménagères
sachant bien que cette lacune expliquer
en grande partie la difficile transition
entre la ctp et la pch
nous savons aussi que cela créera des
obligations au département mais il
s'agira d'une priorité politique que les
uns et les autres définiront ne nous
félicitons aussi de la création d'un
budget annexe
pour le fonds de compensation désormais
individualisé au sein des mdph
cela devrait remédier aux dérives
constatées dans la confusion sinon des
genres du moins des caisses
le deuxième point qui suscite
l'inquiétude des associations
représentatives